autre procès qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui à
amiens celui de gaspard fontaine lame
avait décroché le portrait des manuels
macron le 6 mars 2020 une opération pour
dénoncer le manque d'ambition
gouvernemental en matière de lutte
environnementale
la municipalité par ailleurs ville
natale d'emmanuel macron avait porté
plainte pour vol
le rassemblement de plusieurs dizaines
de personnes a lieu ce matin devant le
tribunal judiciaire de la ville picarde
à l'initiative de l'organisation action
non violente comme 21 parmi les
manifestants plusieurs personnalités
politiques de la france
insoumise comme adrien cnas françois
ruffin ou encore jean luc mélenchon puis
s'expose au ridicule parce que décrocher
un tableau du président moubarak mais
bon c'est un geste symbolique ça m'a
grave personne
the détruit aucun bien ça c'est un geste
symbolique et d'ailleurs ça a marché
c'est exact la tension et vous avez vu
qu'il ya pas longtemps il ya eu un
procès qui a été gagnée contre
l'inaction de l'état en matière de
changement qui mène